meet the candidate of the past she was
12 I was 30 but anyway he's a globalist
creep I got hairy legs and the kids used
to come up and reach in the pool and rub
my leg down looking to sell out his
country America is a nation that can be
defined in a single word I was going to
put him for a chance think about what
you think about to be wined and dined by
his DC political Masters
America's dead but no to end up quote
repeat the line America's dead
hey everybody I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's October 26 2022 we
are live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
Blaze TV if you have not subscribed on
Rumble yet rumble.com Reuben report how
many times do I have to tell you good
people uh what we showed you there in
the cold open that is just a snippet of
a promo from Tucker Carlson who's doing
these uh these documentaries that he
produces on Fox Nation and I just
thought the beginning of that thing was
just absolutely perfect uh the theme of
today's show uh will be this this
closing run that we're in right now the
last few feet before we get to election
day which is less than two weeks it's
from now it's two weeks from yesterday
actually uh because there were three
debates last night
three Senate debates and they were oh no
sorry there were two Senate debates and
one gubernatorial debate uh no two
gubernatorial debates and one Senate
debate all right there we go uh and they
were absolutely disastrous for the
Democrats I mean disastrous now I get it
I get it I got my biases you got your
biases but like if you live on planet
Earth if reality has anything to do with
the universe that you live in these
things were absolute disasters Lee
zeldin crushed I mean absolutely crushed
Kathy hochel uh in New York then of
course there was this this Pennsylvania
one I mean they throwing up this guy
John fetterman who has so many problems
the guy can't speak he had a stroke he
wasn't really the sharpest tool before
that he is just not in good shape and
and Oz just took it to him uh and then
of course uh Gretchen Whitmer uh who in
Michigan who was literally telling
people that they could not Garden during
kovid she got crushed by Tudor Jones I
mean these were really seminal moments
that are consistent with everything
happening in the country so of course
what has to happen what can the machine
do in these two weeks they can't
suddenly have all their candidates get
magically better they can't change all
of their ideas they can't come out uh
you know against all of the things that
they've been for that none of us like so
what can they do they can ramp up the
fear as you know so we've got a
gajillion clips for you today I mean
these debates were just
insane before we get to that real quick
let me talk to you guys about Patriot
mobile you know I recently did a show on
Wolf corporations and their Origins
thankfully conservatives are creating a
parallel economy that is thriving and I
want to tell you about a new sponsor
that's making a real difference Patriot
mobile has exploded over the last year
they're proud conservatives offering a
real alternative for people tired of
funding major cell phone carriers we've
all gone wacky left Patriot mobile is a
force for conservative values this is
because they take a portion of your bill
and fund conservative causes and
candidates people who believe in the
sanctity of Life freedom of speech the
Second Amendment and they're winning in
fact their pack Patriot mobile action
flipped 11 School Board races across
Texas recently Patriot mobile has
affordable plans for you your family
even your business they offer the same
Nationwide coverage as the major
carriers because they use multiple major
networks so you get the same great
service minus the leftist propaganda go
to patriotmobile.com Reuben or call 972
Patriot get free activation when you use
the offer code Reuben special discounts
are available for veterans and First
Responders make the switch today and a
difference tomorrow Patriot mobile.com
Reuben or 972 Patriot and now back to me
okay so let's start
in the great state of Pennsylvania there
is a guy by the name of John fetterman
who is the current lieutenant governor
this is a he's a large man he he wears
hoodies
um he's interested in putting criminals
back out on the streets uh he loves the
woke thing he's muddled and fuddled and
often very confused he did have a stroke
about six months ago I am not making fun
of that or diminishing that but you tell
me after we show you some of these clips
whether you think this guy is fit to be
a senator let's just start with his
opening statement this is this is rather
remarkable this was the first thing that
was said by John fetterman last night as
lieutenant governor you're running for a
seat that could decide the balance of
power in Washington what qualifies you
to be a U.S senator you have 60 seconds
hi good night everybody
I'm running to serve Pennsylvania he's
running to use Pennsylvania
hi good night everybody
that was what you were supposed to say
at the end
uh all right you might be watching that
going Dave Dave he meant to say good
evening you're being a little harsh well
here's about an 80 second compilation of
just endless disaster after disaster
enjoy
now here's what I think we have to fight
about inflation here right now that's
what we need to fight about inflation
and I believe that again my doctors the
real doctors that I believe and they all
believe that I'm ready to be served
that's it you know he got his
Pennsylvania house from his own inlays
from a dollar oh uh I I I do support
fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking okay
now we we all have to make sure that
everyone that works is able to that's
that's the most American bargain that if
you work full-time you should be able to
live in dignity as well true that that's
what I believe I don't ever recall in
the Statue of Liberty that they say you
know you know take our tired huddle
masses and put them on a bus are there
everybody in Braddock have an
overwhelmingly majority uh community of
of black uh Community all understood
what happened you know they they
understood what happened and everybody
agreed that and whether it was a 50 tax
break you know about his farm in
Montgomery County so it's about
supporting and helping you know young
earners excuse me young
young uh young you know students
all right trust me there was way more
the guy is struggling to finish a
sentence now I know that because of Joe
Biden we've become accustomed to
politicians who cannot finish a sentence
but the real question is so let's say
let's say you're watching this show so I
have a sense of what your political
leanings might be you're probably not
big on his ideas of letting all the
criminals out you know you're probably
not being on all his ideas are basically
completely backing the Biden
Administration all of that but putting
that aside if you have a friend who's a
Democrat somewhat on the fence in
Pennsylvania you got to ask them you
really got to ask them like do you think
this guy is fit to be a senator like is
he fit to be a senator really uh but
what's interesting here is that even the
left-wing media after the disastrous
performance last night and you could
feel it you really could feel it his
campaign was going out of the way to
lower expectations they were reminding
everyone he had a stroke they said he's
not the best debater in general you know
he's in every man Dr Oz is a slick TV
personality so they were going out of
their way because they knew this thing
was going to be a disaster but this was
far far worse really it was far worse
than they could have imagined and even
partisan left-wing folks can't cover for
this guy so uh Chris Cuomo who you know
he got kicked off CNN and disgraced he's
got his a new gig now uh here he is
admitting and this Chris is a Democrat
obviously right admitting that fetterman
struggled and wondering a bit about his
health voters I think saw things that
will definitely change the state of this
race it's not his fault but lieutenant
governor Federman struggled
um and again I'm not faulting him for it
I don't think his preparation was great
but he clearly is dealing with health
issues that affect his ability to
process and his ability to speak now in
politics you absolutely have to be able
to
articulate right and argue to and
convince so how you say it matters but
the basic issue is uh is the brain
function intact do you have the ideas
can you form the thoughts
how do you break down those two
different ideas so in the brain
cognition and language are separated but
there's so much interaction between them
so it's hard to say whether his memory
his executive function his ability to
make decisions based on the information
that he receives is impaired
okay so what's interesting about this
and there's a reason I showed you a
Chris Cuomo clip look I obviously I'm
not a big fan of the guy I think he was
a terrible anchor on CNN who got most
things wrong ran cover for his brother
who was uh governor of New York
obviously he's a Democrat activist but I
want to show you that occasionally these
guys sometimes something is so obvious
right it is so in your face that they
have to acknowledge it so again it's
like he's right about the communication
part even if I disagree with all the
fetterman's ideas which I do if he could
articulate those ideas clearly if he
could say these are the things that I
believe in clearly and calmly explain
them then we could have an honest debate
of the issues right this reminded me a
little bit in a way of the the Florida
debate that I was at two days ago
because on one hand you had and again I
my cards are on the table obviously I
like Governor DeSantis but he can
clearly lay out what his policies are
what he has done what he believes and
then you have someone on the other side
who will literally say anything nothing
to do with being with the truth so
that's one version of it and another
version of it is you have Dr Oz who
clearly we're going to show you a clip a
couple clips from Dr Oz in a moment you
have Dr Oz who clearly and calmly lays
out his beliefs and his policies and
then you have a guy who simply cannot do
that that is a an asymmetry that is just
very weird where you know flashback 10
years ago you'd have a Republican and a
Democrat they could both communicate you
at a sense of what they believed for the
most part and they could go at it now
we're having these crazy debates where
either people can't communicate or they
lie about everything or they tell you
that they didn't do the thing that you
know that they did Etc et cetera here is
Dr Oz basically smacking down fetterman
when it comes to border and drugs and
the drug issue is a huge one in Phil in
Pennsylvania especially Philadelphia
area we have a catastrophe at the border
and we should not have Sanctuary cities
as John fetterman has tried to introduce
but I've been into the parts of
Philadelphia and Allentown and reading
where we have large Latino populations I
understand the challenges of the of the
Border my father was an immigrant my
mother were immigrants you know I
understand what legal immigration offers
us but the completely porous open nature
of our border which John Federman
supports has created a humanitarian
crisis with cartels profiting with human
trafficking operations they take the
money they buy narcotics from China and
bring that into our country and it's
making every state a border state
Pennsylvania is already a border state
because we're top three in the country
in fentanyl overdoses at least I can't
go anywhere where in giving a big event
where I don't meet multiple people who
say their personal lives have been
destroyed because of fentanyl overdoses
yet John Federman not only wants an open
border not only supports Sanctuary
cities but he wants to legalize all hard
drugs in America including narcotics
that is I mean out of touch with
everybody that radical position was
tried in Oregon which he endorsed 50
homicide increase rate
I mean pretty freaking obvious what's
going on here right one guy can
communicate their ideas one guy can't
one guy's telling you hey all of the
stuff that he wants to do the
decriminalization of drugs the letting
people out the backing Biden border
policy this is all the stuff that is
destroying our state destroying our
state right interesting stuff and by the
way Dr Oz as I've said many times he's
not a traditional Republican that they
would you know they what they're going
to paint anybody as a Nazi and a fascist
and everything else but this is a guy
who comes in essence although he has
obviously an extensive medical
background but he was on television like
he's can you know he's like sort of like
a little bit of an LA guy like more of
like a California conservative meaning
there's there's a moderate person here
he's he's not some like fire brand
conservative whatever whatever that
thing is that they love to paint
everybody and it's just obvious he can
just calmly explain all of those things
but we'll we'll unpack a bit more from
that debate and then get to New York in
just a moment let me talk to you guys
about real estate agents I trust you
guys know that buying or selling a home
is already one of the most stressful
things you can do and it can be way
worse if you're not working with the
right agent usually our homes are our
biggest investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously which is why I
recommend real estate agents I trust
they work with only the best agents in
every Market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their Network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
Pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their teams make the introduction
and then follow you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied the agents they work
with have long track records and they're
the best sellers in their field and even
under these intense economic conditions
with high interest rate and high
inflation real estate agents I trust
provides their customers with agents
who've overcome these challenges they're
part of this audience they share your
values and they're almost anywhere you
want to go just go over to real estate
agentsitrust.com give them some basic
info their team will contact you to make
an agent to make an introduction to an
agent in your town you move to Florida
and you live happily ever after okay so
the debate obviously I don't think I
need to belabor the point that something
ain't right with fetterman and Dr Oz is
pretty good I think you get it uh so
let's move to a bit of the reaction uh
to the debate uh Chris Cuomo had some
voters on you know this is after these
debates they like to get voters we have
a couple Republicans a couple Democrats
a couple people on the fence and he
started asking these people uh what did
they think uh here is a voter who
thought Dr Oz was pretty good Linwood
what did you think you're a republican
did you like your candidate
Republican did you like your kids I love
my candidate I love new
I love them he was really precise his
answers were crisp and definitely what I
wanted to hear now it's no question
about what people think because he said
it directly out of his mouth I really
loved it all right so Linwood who
appears to be black seems to like Dr Oz
I know it's odd that black people could
vote for Republicans I for one think
that black people can make decisions
outside of the color of their skin but
you know I'm old school uh here is a
independent Pennsylvanian voter talking
about how he's going to change his
position now that he's seen the debate
so I was definitely I'm an independent
by the way I was definitely leaning
towards fetterman and I think I have
totally changed to the Oz side why I
felt that um fetterman I felt that
fetterman just looked like he didn't
have command of the facts I do think his
condition unfortunately is going to
affect his ability to do the job I
thought Oz uh was pretty clear on the
issues and I thought he presented
himself well and uh definitely threw out
some plans where I didn't see any plans
coming out of fetterman okay I know
these things are anecdotal but it's
interesting that you know that there
still are undecided people in the
country is sort of interesting because
the parties are so different right this
isn't like okay am I voting for George
H.W bush or Bill Clinton right where
it's like they both kind of like America
one wants a little bit more taxes you
know but the stuff is kind of the same
to some degree right uh this is like
really really different stuff this is
all of the woke stuff and the open
borders and the race stuff and the crime
and the drugs and the defunding of the
police versus like basic Law and Order
and America's decent and we believe in
the Constitution so I find it
interesting that there are these
undecided type people but this guy
seemed like a decent enough guy and I
think he rep he obviously represents
some sliver of people that are still
undecided maybe it's just that they
don't pay that much attention to
politics except when the elections roll
around and that's that's actually just
fine for a certain segment of the
society uh so it's interesting that he
saw this thing and then it finally hit
him you know he said he was leaning
fetterman so it's hard to understand
like what his political leanings are
maybe that means he's more generally
thought of as a Democrat but after
watching that thing basically he said
fetterman can't communicate his ideas
something ain't quite right and now I'm
going on I I think a lot of people for
whatever sliver of people are still
undecided in Pennsylvania they I cannot
imagine I genuinely cannot but I will if
we can find video of it I will gladly
play it tomorrow if you find me video of
anyone I mean literally anyone please
send it to us of somebody that was like
I watched that debate last night and I
thought John fetterman was excellent I
was on the fence I thought maybe I was
going to vote for Oz and now I'm voting
for John Federman it's I I cannot I
literally cannot imagine that that such
a person could exist but okay
um let's see even now when you go to the
the media coverage portion of all of
this even CNN after the debate uh
realized that they could not run cover
complete cover for fetterman take a look
anyone who's coming into this totally
undecided if you drop a voter into
Harrisburg who had no engagement with
this beforehand it's hard to see them
coming away terribly terribly convinced
by like foreign
it's hard to say they'd be terribly
convinced by Fetter but no it was
freaking awful I'm showing you the clip
because it's like even they had to choke
it out like every now and again that's
what I'm saying if we just keep pushing
on the truth and making the truth
obvious the truth the truth in and of
itself should be obvious but often it
isn't because of big Tech and media and
everything else but if we keep pushing
and showing the clips and saying what is
true then then eventually it chokes out
of the mainstream media and that's what
happened right there you'd have to be
hard-pressed to figure out if somebody
thought fetterman was good no he was an
absolute disaster but I'll take I'll
pill for a little goodness out of CNN
when I can uh but now here is the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC and they were running cover for
fetterman like you wouldn't believe I
think it's also really interesting you
played a lot of Clips there were moments
where he was really strong including
that Bernie Sanders clip including his
very fluent and direct response on
raising the minimum wage I thought was a
really strong moment for him he had some
really really strong comebacks and and
his opponent Oz was first of all he also
fumbled right I fumble on television
right so it's there is I definitely I
was nervous and hesitant at first too
yeah I mean this happens right
um but Oz also was really slippery and
and it it's such pure deflection and
projection uh no you can watch go back
guys like if you feel like it if you're
not doing much today you can watch
unedited the full hour it's a disaster
for fetterman there really were no good
moments and this idea that some people
fumble that Oz fumble look I do a show
that is live every single day I do
fumble over things sometimes sometimes
even if I'm looking in the prompter and
and we're not totally lined up I start
going off on a tangent and Phoenix has
to catch up with me but everything I say
is off the top of my head so
occasionally I'm going to mess up a word
I'm going to stumble or stumble or
whatever but that's not what we're
talking about here the idea that Oz did
anything close to what fetterman did is
completely ridiculous but this is what
they do they run cover for these people
while then attacking us she was also
implying that Oz was being mean about
fetterman's condition which simply
wasn't true and it's just people can see
it people can see it so uh let's move on
from that one I think I made the point
and again please if you can find
somebody on this planet Earth on this
pale blue dot if you can find somebody
that was convinced that John fetterman
was the better candidate last night I'd
love to find him I'd love to talk to him
it would be it would be truly
fascinating so the other uh debate last
night uh which was a gubernatorial
debate was Lee zeldin Republican in New
York running against Kathy hokel now
Kathy as you know no one voted for her
she was the lieutenant governor under
Andrew Cuomo he stepped down in shame
they install her and she immediately
became worse and I note that because it
happened not this past August but the
August before and I was off the grid
when it happened and Adam Carolla
brought me back on the grid you may
remember that and he said they that
Cuomo stepped down and before he told me
that Kathy hokel was the woman coming in
uh I said you can we should have we
should have grabbed the video maybe
we'll grab it for tomorrow I said I
guarantee you whoever it is it's going
to be worse and I said suppose I was
right because Kathy locked everybody
down she still wants to force people to
get injections she has Unleashed insane
crime in New York New York I didn't even
know this until last night New York has
lost even more people than California I
mean just the list of craziness just
goes on and on and on so here is Lee
zeldin who not many people knew about
Lee zeldin until about two weeks ago he
strikes me as like a decent guy as I
said the other day he strikes me as the
the father that would pick you up after
school and and take you out for ice
cream or something with your friends uh
here he is he was a pretty solid debater
and passionate and I was very impressed
with him here he is destroying Kathy on
crime but it's about getting the guns
off the streets that's the first start
we have more to do but I'm the one to do
it did you want to respond yes yeah of
course and unfortunately Kathy hokel
believes that the only crimes that are
being committed are these crimes with
guns and you've got people who are
afraid of being pushed in front of
oncoming subway cars they're being
stabbed beaten to death on the street
with hammers go talk to the Asian
American community and how it's impact
them with the loss of lives Jewish
people targeted with raw violent
anti-Semitism on our streets it just
happened yet again we need to be talking
about all of these other crimes but
instead Kathy hogle's too busy patting
herself on the back job well done no
actually right now there should be a
special session the state legislature
should come back and they should
overhaul cast a spell and these other
pro-criminal laws with zero tolerance
but they're saying elect me she says
elect me and then you'll find out where
maybe I'll stand on this issue in
January
I like the guy I like his body language
maybe that's just me as a New Yorker
like I feel like he cares and I don't
even know that you know it's not like
the greatest uh gig in the world to be a
Republican and try to run for governor
of New York although we have had uh
Republican governors in New York
obviously George Pataki that's only what
15 20 years ago through term Governor he
was pretty decent uh so you know it's
not that this doesn't happen but it's
like it's not easy to go through that
machine which is so Democrat run the
same way it is in California they're
going to treat you like crap just ask
Larry Elder but I I thought that his his
response his passion the clarity was
excellent and you know again this is one
of those things you don't really have to
listen to the politician just call if
you're not living in if you live in New
York you know it but if you got a friend
in New York call him after this show
how's it going in New York do you feel
like crime is better or worse do you
feel safe when you're on the subway my
mother-in-law lives in New York City now
I have told her repeatedly not to use
the subway anymore uh like that's real
that is actually real and it's not just
gun violence as zeldin pointed out
people are literally being stabbed
they're being pushed into Subways I mean
it's bad I was in New York a couple
weeks ago it does not feel like New York
City the city that I grew up in and
loved for many many years that spent
most of my adult life and which you know
New York if you can make it here you can
make it anywhere now it's basically New
York we got weed on every corner all
right but it's not just that she's bad
on crime she's been she was one of the
most Draconian lockdown jab promoters in
the country and guess what she would do
it all over again you've been an
election denier a climate change denier
you and Donald Trump were the masterful
coveted deniers we are dealing with the
real crisis and the more people get
vaccinated get those shots in arms and I
would do it all over again what I did
last year that mandate for health care
workers
absolutely vile and disgusting and if
you were in New York and you vote for
her then you you will get exactly what
you deserve you will have a bureaucrat
telling you when you should inject
yourself in a vaccine that does not work
that's what you will do you will be
injecting your children with some [ __ ]
that you have no idea what it is zeldin
made a very clear point that he would
not be doing that the fact that she has
no remorse of what they did and
destroyed the economy and and destroyed
so so many people's lives and forced so
many people out of the state and she
would do it all over again
we thought it would be fun to throw back
to this this is former New York City
Mayor Bill de Blasio a true communist
crackpot when he was offering a Shake
Shack yeah you could get a burger and
fries if you just got their experimental
vaccine
I got vaccinated
you're saying I could get this
delicious fries
bye Matt
but there's also a burger element to
this
let me let me check with Bill needhart
is it too early in the day to eat a
burger no this could be breakfast okay
I want you to look at this and think
about
again
some people love hamburger some don't
really want to respect all ways of life
but if this is appealing to you just
think of this when you think of
vaccination
um
I'm getting a very good feeling
Democrats are psychopaths
good night everybody or good evening
these people are completely insane like
that the fact that that ever happened
that that was not a Saturday Night Live
skit and the fact that Kathy hokel would
dare say she would do it all over again
well Kathy whether you remain Governor
or not you got a major major problem uh
because uh no New York is not putting up
with it this is actually spectacular
this happened just yesterday we've got
some info from the daily wire on what's
happening to the unvaccinated who New
York Smackdown pretty hard unvaccinated
New York City workers scored a victory
Monday after a New York Supreme Court
Judge ruled the city's vaccine mandate
which Kathy hokel is for and said she
has no regrets about for all city
employees is arbitrary capricious I love
the word capricious and unconstitutional
New York City Democratic mayor Eric
Adams fired roughly 2 000 Municipal
workers including police officers and
firefighters earlier this year who
refused to comply with the covid
vaccination mandate the court found that
being vaccinated does not prevent an
individual from Contracting or
transmitting covid-19 adding that
vaccinated and unvaccinated individuals
have the same quarantine and isolation
guidelines issued by the Centers for
Disease Control and prevention the
vaccine mandate for city employees was
not just about safety and public health
it was about compliance judge Ralph
porzio wrote in his ruling if it was
about safety and public health
unvaccinated workers would have been
placed on leave the moment the order was
issued on Monday the New York state
supreme court further ruled that all
employees terminated for their
vaccination status would be reinstated
and received back pay for violating
their rights so first off I just want to
say if you in New York City were one of
these people and you were put out of
work and I met people when I was on tour
in New York I pulled the crowd about who
was vaccinated who wasn't there was a
whole group of nurses there
several of them who were fired and put
on leave because they didn't want to get
vaccinated ladies at that table to my
right at the show I am applauding you
today and I'm very excited that you will
not only get your jobs back but you're
going to get that back pay and and
you're obviously not going to vote for
that crazy woman and thankfully the
courts are are ultimately doing the
right thing it's a miracle but they're
doing it and let's not forget we would
all still write this very moment be
wearing masks which don't work on planes
if it was not for that what I think 36
year old Trump appointed female judge in
Tampa who struck it down and then the
next day everyone took their masks off
and there was no massive outbreak of
covid and everything else the vaccines
do not work these people are liars and
frauds and they want you on the Dole
forever they don't want you to talk
about any of the side effects and it's
like man you turn on any TV show and
every freaking ad is for another drug
you know they want some mind-bending
drug or Adderall or whatever it might be
and they then the half the commercial is
all the side effects but for some reason
with this thing uh no we're not allowed
to talk about the side effects Lee
zeldin continued to hammer Kathy on this
and made it very very clear about how he
feels about mandates my opponent just
said she will not mandate coveted
vaccines at this time let me be clear to
all the parents who are out there I will
not mandate coveted vaccines for your
kids ever
I don't believe that there should be
coveted vaccine mandates right now for
our kids at SUNY and CUNY in community
colleges and elsewhere where just over a
year ago a whole bunch of Heroes were
turning into zeros tens of thousands of
people because of my opponent's health
care worker coveted vaccine what about
polio vaccine would you I believe that I
just finished the point I I believe that
that mandate was wrong and that everyone
who has been fired should be offered
their jobs back with back pain there
shouldn't be any special celebrity covid
vaccine mandates
yeah pretty sweet man and again it's
just it's just one guy just saying
enough is enough I'm going to tell you
the truth and I am not as a he wants to
be elected as an elected official I am
not here to own the autonomy over your
body and your life pretty sweet so okay
Let's uh let's do a little recap here
disastrous debate the Whitmer debate was
also a disaster for her we'll show you
some clips on that one tomorrow but just
a disastrous debates I've been showing
you the polling I mean it looks like the
Republicans are probably going to get 53
seats in the Senate everyone hates the
woke aoc's having a nervous breakdown
like it's all becoming obvious there's a
new crop of decent Republicans like it's
it's good there is goodness here we can
get to the other side of this thing so
what do they have to do I mean I've been
saying this for a year what will they
have to do they'll have to bring back
covid 6 monkey pox nine we got a a war
in Ukraine and a dirty bomb and the rest
of it so yeah they're doing exactly
exactly what I said this is Joe Biden
yesterday trying to scare the hell out
of you over covet again this is a global
Health Emergency if you really want to
put cover behind us we have to keep up
the fight together
no liar buffoon fraud that's what you
are Joe and in two weeks hopefully you
will be a lame duck as well well you're
a lame duck as is it is not a worldwide
health emergency everyone knows it they
are just trying to scare the hell out of
you and it's very bizarre because it was
only one month ago that Joe Biden said
this is the pandemic over the pandemic
is over we still have a problem with
covet we're still doing a lot of work on
it uh it's but the pandemic is over oh
the pandemic was over a month ago now
we're two weeks from elections and you
freaks who all of your ideas are bad and
everyone is rejecting you all you've got
is fear so you're ramping it up again I
mean it is absolutely extraordinary uh
but it is completely consistent with
what these people did here's a little
bit more from Biden yesterday fear fear
fear fear fear
virtually every cover death in America
is preventable virtually everyone almost
everyone who will die from Kobe this
year will not be up to date on their
shots or they will not have taken Pax
lovid when they got sick
nonsense you liar and buffoon the
vaccine does not stop you from getting
coveted it does not stop you from
transmitting covid I know that every
time one of these uh NPC covid people
blue check Democrat uh you know robots
who I know every time one of them gets
covered they have to say oh it would
have been much worse if not for the
vaccine but there are no studies to
prove that there are none please send
them to me if you can find them uh they
do not exist uh but this is very odd
because uh let me just get this straight
Biden is now saying that everyone's got
to get vaxed again and all the people
who don't get vacs those are going to be
the ones that are dying but I'm not so
sure that his track record on this is
really great here's Joe Biden on
December 16 2021 this is this is going
to go down as one of Biden's Greatest
Hits I think
for unvaccinated we are looking at a
winner of severe illness and death for
unvaccinated for themselves their
families and the hospitals they'll soon
overwhelm
disgusting I mean it's absolutely
disgusting so that was about 10 months
ago and then you know what happened we
got Omicron basically everybody got
coveted over that Christmas week into
New Year's and most people not only not
just most people it was a mild flu for
most people I got it I did have leg
pains for a couple days I did I did I
admitted I had leg pains I am not
vaccinated I am never getting vaccinated
come for me you freaks
um but you can see what they're doing
guys you could see it no one thinks
covet is really coming back right now
but this is all they've got know their
playbook and that's how you beat them uh
here's black lesbian press secretary
Karin Jean-Pierre refusing to say if the
government's ever going to give up their
National Emergency Powers what is the
criteria the country would have to meet
for it not to be a national emergency or
is that even a goal so here's the thing
we cannot forget that covet is still a
problem we just had Dr Jacques here
talking to all of you he wanted to be
here and we wanted him to be to all of
you because you guys communicate uh with
the American people and we want we want
that the American people to know that
there is a new vaccine out there and
they need to get that shot in the arm no
you don't need to get it and you don't
have to listen to these people they are
not your parents they are not your
doctor they are not your conscience and
they are not your God I know they'd like
to be all of those things but they are
none of those things you know how to
take care of yourself and that must be
the Republican message going forward and
it is and you can see it Oz said it last
night
um zeldin said it last night what has
Blake Masters been saying what has
Carrie Lake been saying what has JD
Vance been saying the the discrepancy
and the Divide between the parties has
never been more clear do you want a
bunch of Mind muddled bureaucrats to
force you to do things with your body
and inject your children with things and
then they'll chop their genitals off as
a bonus or do you want to be left alone
with a little more money in your pocket
with a little more chance that it's on
you how you will live your life it's up
to you it's up to you man but I am
telling you the machine is going to go
into overdrive for the next 12 days or
so and they're going to try to freak
everybody out not only with covid but
fascism is coming and the Nazis are back
at everything else here's televised
mental institution MSNBC with my
favorite racist host Joy Reid we talk
about this all the time democracy on the
ballot it's not just a slogan you know I
mean we're talking about women literally
losing agency over themselves Donald
Trump has said you know where he's going
to challenge the election already in
advance he says he's going to do it
Philly it's a dog whistle right I mean
it's not even being hidden at this point
it's just fascism in the open I mean I'm
not calling I'm not going to say that
you know the GOP or Nazis at this point
or whatever but it certainly sounds very
familiar to what happened in Germany
which is a bunch of citizens Davidoff
Hitler gets a third of the vote nobody
thought it could happen there they kind
of went along because they said he was
going to solve the economy and fix
inflation yeah that's right those sorts
of
things
absolute fear-mongering nonsense and
even the Chiron did you see the Chiron
at the end anti-Semitism On The Rise
well first off the hate crimes against
Jews are just it's just it's always
there Jews are always the number one
it's always number one uh the segment
obviously was about what Kanye's been
saying I have no defense of Kanye he
should not be defended uh but do you
think they ever do the anti-semitisms On
The Rise story uh when they're talking
about all of the black people who were
beaten the Orthodox Jews in Brooklyn or
how about Ilan Omar do they ever bring
her on they actually brought I mean this
was an incredible video from last week
they brought ilhan Omar to talk about
the rise of anti-Semitism I mean it's
just these people are you gotta they
should be studied they need to be
studied I'm not going to say it's like
Hitler but it is like Hitler it's not
like Nazi Germany but Nazis fascists and
now they're so concerned with what you
do with your body it's wild the same
people who want to still inject you with
all this stuff but every now and again
as I said before truth because the truth
cannot be stopped I really believe that
there is something the truth is such a
fundamental
uniter of what of what drives Humanity
truth that every now and again it gets
choked out even by the people who lie
about everything so Joe Scarborough who
gets everything wrong who I think he
pretends to be a Republican or something
but he's a Democrat he would do anything
he could to destroy any Republican we've
played all sorts of videos he's taken
every position on everything here he is
occasionally getting something right
about this overuse of the term Nazi
people my entire adult life say oh your
parents switched from being Democrats to
Republicans in 1968 because they were
racist and your family was racist and
everybody in the South was racist
because Richard Nixon had a southern no
no my parents are raising like three
kids and 68 69 70. they saw what
happened in Chicago they saw Riots of
the Democratic National Convention they
saw the radical ISM they believe uh in
in the Democratic party on the far left
and no it wasn't related to civil rights
uh but it was related to a lot of
bombings and a lot of extreme Behavior
so yeah if we want to just simplify
everything and go oh
well if somebody's still supporting for
Trump they must be a racist we're not
going to get anywhere
I'm pretty sure uh Chuck Scarborough is
not going to be invited to the MSNBC
weekly dinner
with Joy Reid because he just absolutely
debunked everything she said people
generally even back then did not vote
because they want to oppress a group of
people based on the color of their skin
they vote a certain way because they'd
like to walk out of their house and feel
safe they vote a certain way because
they want the economy to be chugging
along so they can open up that small
business and follow their dreams you
know that Pursuit of Happiness thing so
it's sort of ironic that Joe is kind of
realizing that about his own family why
did his own family become Republicans
back in the late 60s early 70s it was
because of the same issues that many
people are becoming Republicans right
now but tomorrow he'll be out there
calling people racists and bigots and
everything else but now this is really
the next part so when I tell you that
they're bringing covet back it's obvious
right I mean I've been saying this for
weeks they're doing it right in front of
our eyes
um when I tell you that they've got bad
ideas and they just keep doubling down
on those bad ideas okay that one's
pretty obvious too so what's the next
thing that they have to do right in
front of our face and this one you
really really got to pay attention to
they are now because they know they're
about to get crushed they are going to
be the ones questioning election
integrity and they're seeding the ground
with it remember they did it for four
years under under Trump because they
didn't have the guy they wanted so it
was Russia collusion Trump's an
illegitimate president they were allowed
to do it they were also allowed to burn
down cities and stores and all that
stuff then they get the guy they want
they get by it and suddenly
we can't talk about any of this stuff if
you question elections we're going to
boot you off YouTube we're gonna censor
things like the hunter Biden laptop
everyone else everyone's a conspiracy
theorist there was an Insurrection okay
but they are seeding the ground right
now to make it so that all Democrats
will be questioning elections here's
Nicole Wallace and once again on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC she's telling her people if we
lose it's because of fraud I mean this
is the subtext of what she's saying and
uh who could help us maybe we get the UN
in on this yeah they're good but if you
read through the papers this weekend the
threats to our elections in what two and
a half weeks are so pervasive and
they're so dire and they include
violence I mean do you think it's time
to ask for friends and allies to come
over and help us monitor our elections
we used to do that in other burgeoning
and threatened democracies
yeah no Nicole I'm not there yet and I
know why you're asking what you're
asking and you're not wrong
okay do you see it do you see it how
much more obvious could it be they know
they're gonna get thumped and they want
their audience to know it will not be
legit this is very much like uh what was
it two days ago that we played you that
clip from CNN where they're literally
reporting on record early voting and the
Chiron on the bottom is talking about
voter suppression you have to have some
sympathy for the NPCs that that watch
this stuff and that are just brainwashed
right but they are seeding the ground
for violence they are seeding the ground
for questioning elections and all of
those things the things that all the
stuff that we were not allowed to do
that's what they're doing and guess
who's back and lead in The Charge yeah
Hillary Clinton I know we're all focused
on the 2022 midterm elections and they
are incredibly important
but we also have to look ahead
because you know what our opponents
certainly are
right-wing extremists already have a
plan to literally steal the next
presidential election and they're not
making a secret of it
the right wing controlled Supreme Court
may be poised to rule on giving State
legislatures Yes you heard me that
correctly State legislatures the power
to overturn presidential elections
just think if that happens the 2024
presidential election
could be decided not by the popular vote
or even by the anachronistic electoral
college
but by state legislatures
many of them republican-controlled
first off as she knows the presidential
election is not decided by the popular
vote and the anachronistic Electoral
College okay Hillary but you can see
what they're doing you can see it right
now she said white right wing extremists
literally have a plan there must be a
plan it's odd because during that
Insurrection thing nobody brought a plan
there was one guy who maybe bought a
brought a had a Lego set remember that
guy I don't know what happened to that
guy nobody had a plan that day it was
over within three hours but now they
literally have a plan and and it's
interesting because uh as I saw this
video yesterday I was thinking hasn't
Hillary been talking about right wing
conspiracies for a long time she's been
doing this for quite some time I had
Connor put this together for you
right-wing extremists already have a
plan to literally steal the next
presidential election this vast
right-wing conspiracy that has been
conspiring against my husband since the
day he announced for president I'm here
to highlight something that is keeping
me up at night
yeah okay she's been talking about vast
right-wing conspiracies and right-wing
extremists for a long time that vast
right-wing conspiracy that she was
talking about that was you know 25 years
ago or so that was about whether Bill
Clinton had in effect raped Monica
Lewinsky turns out that he just took a
cigar and actually put it up her while
he was on the phone with Trent Lott
are we doing a family show today or what
you know it's just it is what it is what
are you gonna do Google it don't Google
image it but Google it
um yeah Hillary not a good person but
you can see what they're doing this is
exactly what they're doing and guess
what guys Believe It or Not despite the
way the polls are going and despite what
we all think is going to happen uh the
machine is still cracking down in all
sorts of ways uh Fox did a piece on how
Google is manipulating search results to
interfere with the election right now
meantime Google's being accused of
manipulating its search results to work
against Republicans running in major
Senate races across the country the
media Research Center finding 10 out of
uh 10 out of 12 Republican campaign
websites and key Senate races got
significantly lower search results
compared to their Democrat opponents
seven others Republican candidates did
not have their campaign sites appear on
the first page while eight Democrats had
their websites among the top results
so you guys get it they have the machine
they have all of the mainstream media to
run cover for them they have big Tech to
manipulate search results so that
perhaps if you're trying to find a
republican you end up at the Democrat
website or at some story about the
Republican that is not even an honest
story like you guys get all that that's
why we just have to keep our eye on the
ball and not lose our nerve we are we
really are close to fixing this thing we
really could be there if the Republicans
get the Senate and the house back and
then Biden's just a lame duck they'll
take him out and then we could just get
back to something normal we're right
there but they have to scare the hell
out of you right at the end of the
Finish Line that's what they have to do
so what do I always say you also have to
do you have to clearly and calmly
explain your position and then let
people make decisions for themselves you
don't have to use fear if you have the
truth the Democrats all they have now is
fear the Nazis are coming for you the
fascists are coming for you all of that
stuff
but what do we have we have the truth
here's Dr Oz's closing statement I
thought it was quite excellent and
actually aspirational and uh not muddled
I love traveling to the four corners of
the beautiful Commonwealth and I've
heard your problems I'm a surgeon doctor
I listened to what you say and I'm
trying to help address them today I've
talked to seniors where their Social
Security checks wouldn't go far enough
with the Raging inflation I've talked to
couples when I make their first down
payment on a new house and they can't
afford it anymore because of interest
rates I've talked to families you want
to cut Social Security Mr fetterman it's
his term for his closing I've talked to
families worried about fentanyl showing
up in their mailbox and literally taking
the lives of their children who they
find blue in bed I I've talked to
families who won't let the kids go
outside because of the crime wave that's
been facilitated by left radical
policies like the ones John fetterman
has been advocating for but here's the
deal right none of this has to happen
this is all very addressable I'm a
surgeon I'm not a politician we take big
problems we focus on them and we fix
them we do it by uniting by coming
together not dividing
and by doing that we can get ahead but
I've got one question to challenge you
with just one question if you take what
I'm saying to Heart ask yourself this
and others in your family are you
unhappy with where America is headed
I am and if you are as well
that I'm the candidate for change
I'm a living embodiment of the American
dream
solid man like that's solid right it
echoes a little bit of of Reagan when he
was first running against Jimmy Carter
back in uh whatever it was 1980 right
are you better off now than you were
with this guy and everyone knows the
answer is no so
uh there was another line in there that
I really liked I wrote it down none of
this has to happen that's what he said
none of this has to happen we all let
this thing happen and again I I include
myself in that we all let this woke
thing in we let horrible ideas in we let
children's genital mutilation in we let
rabid racism into our system we let
equity in we basically uh tested
communism and socialism in our system
but we don't have to we do not have to
and as he said these problems are
addressable you know how we address
these problems we just don't get rid of
a certain set of people that are in
politics right now meaning vote them out
vote them out fetterman should not be a
senator okay hochul should not be a
governor Whitmer has got to go
eventually Joe Biden's got to go Kamala
Harris has to go AOC has to go these
people who have ushered in all of this
stuff you can go do something else I
don't know that you guys have a lot of
skills to do a lot of other things AOC
can go be a bartender or whatever it is
they can go do those things again but
you cannot be the politicians anymore we
have let the inmates run the Asylum for
too long it's over and now it's time to
get back to something a little bit
better will the Republicans ultimately
disappoint us most likely
most likely but will they let's just say
move the Titanic a little bit away from
the iceberg yeah probably probably and I
think it would be best if we did not Jam
straight into the iceberg all right we
got a great cold close for you that will
sort of sum up everything we've been
talking about here but some comments
from the locals Community talway says
fetterman's so bad on that debate even
the Amish lost faith and they don't use
TVs that's funny that is funny I mean
Amish
Catholic Jewish Muslim atheist you
cannot be watching veteran and thinking
this is good really genuinely please
somebody find me Phoenix this is your
job for the rest of the day I want you
to clear out your calendar I want you to
get out there and find me someone that
was like I saw that John fetterman last
night I like him and I support him find
me that person I will fly them to
Florida to talk because it can't be uh
Torrid says after this debate if
fetterman wins its confirmation that the
vote is rigged
it's hard to imagine it's actually hard
to imagine and yet Bizarro things happen
in politics every freaking day right
they really do
um
we shall see but how about how about we
just have some election security you
know it's interesting in in Marco
Rubio's debate debate with Val demings
couple days ago he was asked I think did
we play the clip I think we played the
clip he was asked whether he would uh
honor the results of the debate and he
said hey he said hey we have great
election Integrity here in Florida of
course he said I'm going to win but of
course I'm going to acknowledge it
valdemings refused to so they are sowing
the seeds they're planting those seeds
and they are sowing and laying the
groundwork for violence Insurrection and
other stuff uh Rich says question of the
day who should be the next crop of
Florida Governors well that's
interesting look I again
I do not know what Rhonda Santos's plans
are I think you can make arguments both
ways that he should stay here and
fortify this state and the states matter
more than the country to some extent
um but I think clearly you can make an
argument that in essence he has been the
leader of the country he is the right
Republican he is younger he is effective
like you can make all of those arguments
so but putting that aside to directly
answer your question I mean I think
there's there's a couple people here
that would be excellent I like Miami
mayor Francis Suarez a lot I really like
him a lot I think he's done an
incredible job here in Miami we have
almost no crime despite all of the
people that come here and go to South
Beach and are partying all the time we
have less than a thousand homeless
people in Miami right now what is I
think Los Angeles has something like 70
000 like it's real and people want if
you were homeless where would you want
to live you'd love to live in Miami the
weather is great like you know you don't
want to live in a cold place
um he is you know the what they've done
with tech what they've done with taxes
what they've done to make it comfortable
for businesses to come here they are
trying to solve a lot of the things you
know the one issue in Florida for sure
is house prices right it's house prices
is an issue all over the country but in
a place where everybody's coming where
literally hundreds of thousands of
people are coming from across the
country hundreds of thousands of people
are moving south they are coming here
this is this is the this is the new
promised land and what that does is a
bunch of people come in with all sorts
of money they start competing the house
market goes nuts the rents go up my guys
know that and it create it does create a
legit problem I would say it's a good
problem to have because it means more
resources are coming here they'll put
more money into infrastructure and all
those things but that does need to be
addressed for sure that's something that
that has to be dealt with at the city
level Suarez it's something that has to
be dealt with at the uh at the FED at
the state level DeSantis so
we shall see Florida's got a bright
future either way but let's let's see if
we can fix this country I think we can
uh guys as always if you haven't
subscribed yet please join us at
rumble.com reubenreport and if you want
to play along during the show for live
chat and I put pictures of the kids and
a bunch more uh you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with Andrew Clavin is up right
now across platforms my full interview
with David sacks all about Ukraine is up
the Cleveland one is up ad free uh well
both of them are up ad free on locals as
always and we leave you with Hillary
Clinton denying the election goodbye we
know the Russians
hacked the DNC
hacked my campaign Etc Trump knows he's
an illegitimate president who got
illegitimate foreign health I do think
that he knows uh that uh he's an
illegitimate president I believe he
knows he's an illegitimate president you
can run the best campaign
you can even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you
[Applause]